former general manager of the Los
Angeles Dodgers and not just any a man
who had a winning record an eight of his
nine seasons in the chair and the author
of the big chair of the smooth hops and
bad bounces from the inside world of the
acclaimed Los Angeles Dodgers general
manager that you can still get on
bookstores online everywhere TV analyst
for Sportsnet la Ned Colletti here in
the flesh good to see you again to see
you rich always a pleasure all right
let's start let's start with the
defending national league champs right
now eight games back Ryu now out until
the all-star break Seager out for the
year Turner we don't know when he's
gonna be back I mean I guess the list
could go on and on what is your thoughts
on the Dodger start so well it's
obviously been a rough start after a
great year a year ago injuries always
play into it injuries are always a piece
of it no doubt but they've been hit
harder than most and they've got a lot
of depth in their organization but I
think the way that they've they've had
the injuries hit it's gonna be difficult
without getting guys back it's really
get back on track
so eight out right now what's your
what's your history and being on a team
that's eight out you know for the season
I go back to the 2013 season at one
point I'm late June really we were Don
Mattingly was our manager people were
thinking he was going to get fired he
didn't he continued to right the ship we
were I think twelve out and nine nine
and a half or twelve under five hundred
and nine and a half games out in late
June so many different things are gonna
happen the blessing and the curse of
baseball you play it every day so the
blessing and the curse of baseball is
evaluated every day and if you evaluate
it too quick you'll make mistakes that
said the team has been under 500 for a
while and they do have a lot of injuries
they got to get Turner back that's
probably three weeks away Logan
foresight get him back I still think
they're gonna make a run at it they know
how to win Arizona learned a little bit
last year how to win but they still
Dodgers have got a good pedigree a great
culture great manager and Roberts so I
think they'll make it a race before it's
over what's your read on why Corey
Seager had got the injury that he got
the winner a shortstop is uh it's
probably the one position that you throw
from so many different arm slots and you
throw quick and you have to throw
accurate and obviously hard
got him except for the catcher and maybe
a right fielder probably your best arm
is your shortstop and I think just to
wear and tear different things like that
accumulate and I think that's what
that's what happened to Cory he
obviously did not want to have this
happen he was hurting last year and
decided against the surgery because he
thought he could heal he wasn't prepared
to do what what nature is gonna make him
do so it's not because he's at the
spinal tap 11 and he couldn't dial it
back with all the extra swings that had
nothing to do with it you don't think I
don't think so it's really just an arm
angle from the ort stuff I think so I
think it's I think it's that I think
when you think about pitchers pitchers
hardly ever hit and yet and that that's
where most of the time you John
surgeries are coming from so I do think
it's a throwing a throwing issue I think
that's that's most of it and I think
that the arm angles are tough and I
you've got a there's been I think 34 in
fields that have a Tommy John surgery in
the last thirty years so it's rare that
it would happen to an infielder most of
them and the high 90s come back as good
as they were before the end of that
before the surgery but I do think it's
it's really a wear and tear injury that
that builds up like that a couple more
questions on the Dodgers specifically
before we move on with Ned Colletti
you're the perfect person to ask about
what gives with Kenley Jansen since you
were the guy said maybe we should make
you a reliever yeah so what I mean this
is this pretty much the first adversity
he's ever faced in the position he's
looking mortal all of a sudden most
relievers eventually do what's your
evaluation of what what ales Johnson I
think it's really related to the spring
training in a lot of ways I think the
Dodgers last year were really wise and
how they used their pitching they were
very judicious and how they use their
starters I think Kershaw led the staff
at 175 innings typically you'll see
somebody go to 10 to 20 then pitched a
month of October on top of that they
were very judicious in all their usage
and I think it carries over to the
spring Kenley threw up hardly at all
this spring in in regular spring
training games and it was really to kind
of give him maybe an extra month to
recoup your plate on November 1st your
offseason is a month shorter than the
teams that didn't make it plus it's a
different month of October is different
than any other month you're ever going
to play I think all that stuff adds up
so I think there were wise and kind of
you know keeping them back a little bit
and this
bring and I think that that's what
you're seeing you're still seeing him
come out of spring training really it's
probably it's probably a week in my mind
maybe a week into the regular season now
even though we're a month in but as far
as his development this year I think I
think it was wise to wait this team is
built for October so they know that
that's a month they're gonna have to
really have everybody in the best spot
that they can be and it far be it for me
or anybody I guess to tell Dave Roberts
a perennial manager of the Year
candidate how to handle his players or
know how to push a button I mean yasiel
puig is a perfect example of how to
rehabilitate a player that needs that
sort of mental rehab so what what is the
scoop with bench and Cody Bellinger I
mean that did I saw the play it didn't
look like he was jacking it to me this
it does this kid does he reading his
press clippings a little bit now you
don't know that's the one thing and I've
learned a lot in my 30-some years in the
sport there's a lot of things I don't
know and I don't know what goes on
behind closed doors and I don't know all
conversations that do take place I have
great respect for Dave Roberts I have
great respect for Cody Bellinger and it
was one of those situations that hit a
flashpoint and and Dave had had seen
enough and took him out of the game
after Dublin in the right-center field
that in San Francisco thinking he should
have been on third base you talked to
Cody after the game and Cody says hey
when I was a breaking ball by the time I
finished my swing I was down on one knee
time I got up and started running I
didn't want to get thrown out at third
base so there's there's a thought
process to his part of the they play but
Dave Roberts is the manager and Dave
Roberts is going to just set forth what
he expects we've all seen Dave Roberts
as a player there Roberts took nothing
off ever and not to say that Cody took
that play off but we don't know all the
detail that has transpired he did what
he did
Dave Roberts said what he said and I
think that they put it behind him and
then will for it I think it's a lesson
to be learned and I think that Cody's
are respectful enough player and person
that probably won't ever happen again
all right I want to take a break in
netting you come back well I want to hit
you on this ridiculous epidemic of
striking a major league baseball more
strikeouts and hits in a
for the first time ever we're already
off to a roaring start in May with James
Paxton striking out 16 batters and the
Yankees and the Astros having half the
outs be more than half the outs be
strikeouts in a four nothing game and
what ails the sport and how it can be
fixed because to me that's more of a
problem than pace of play to me okay and
then I want to hit on a couple other
items but we hit in earlier on it the
the 3000 hit Club that pulse is gonna
get it and who might be the next one to
get in if are we are we seeing just a
changing of the way that this sport is
played and so much more 844 204 rich is
the number to dial those who are on hold
for hashtag dear Adele to foe stay on
hold that's gonna be coming up after our
chat with Ned Colletti here on the
Richardson show Ned Colletti former
Dodger is GM and analyst right now for
Sportsnet la here in studio and breaking
news I you know we were talking about
the 3000 hit Club and pulse is going to
join it current active leaders and hits
Ichiro Suzuki number one with 3089 and
Adrian Beltre just 14 behind him to
catch him Adrian Beltre is now the
active leader cuz Ichiro just retired
today and announced that the Mariners
announcing just five minutes ago the
word coming out of the Pacific Northwest
that he is retiring and is transitioning
to a role as the special assistant to
the chairman of the Seattle Mariners an
active presence with the major league
club will be set at both at home in
Seattle and on the road Ichiro Suzuki
zs-- Hall of Fame career tremendous
career he's over now it was this so each
row just I guess deciding to stop
playing and him going to the front
office prevents him from being signed by
another club correct yeah but if he's
done playing he's probably done play
probably wanted to finish where he began
in this country you know but will you
think about what he did and he didn't
start here until he was about 27 or 28
years old right he wasn't a 21 22 year
old coming up and had an extra five or
six years he started late and still oh
yeah yeah what a what a tremendous
career what will you say people
call him me all-time head King more than
P Bros because you can add and what he
did in Japan to on top to the of the
3089 hit I think it's apples and oranges
of some extent pitching's different
situations are different so apples and
oranges 3089 career hits for Ichiro
Suzuki dip tremendous baseball yeah just
tremendous slap hitter everywhere may
have had a shot of four thousand Eddie
come here at twenty one twenty two years
old correct you know instead pool holes
too shy of the 3000 hit Club you looked
at the list that we were looking at
before and the four check marks that I
have that anybody with a chance to get
to 3,000 hits
I've got Cabrera Miguel Cabrera who is
about three hundred and forty is exactly
three hundred and thirty five hit shy
Robinson Cano who is five hundred and
ninety four hits shy and then Jose
Altuve and Mike Trout who are in the
thousands right now Altuve is about 1700
plus hit shy and trout almost 2,000 hits
shy but because of their age those are
the only ones on this list you took a
look at the list this list do you agree
I agree certainly with with Cabrera and
Cano the other two players trout and
Altuve are tremendous players but
there's so much time that they're gonna
have to play to get to that point that's
a long way to go yet and yet different
things that happen injuries happen
different things they're certainly
talented enough to get there but
longevity is up to time you know that's
up to father time sometimes yeah I'm
gonna tasks l0 the Rich Eisen show
researcher word something what is the
longest span in between 3000 hit Club
entries because we might be staring on
in the face right now yes why is that
why is it is it because of the the
number of strikeouts can we draw a line
between the current seeming epidemic
that just happened in April first month
in the history of Major League Baseball
more strikeouts than hits can we draw a
straight line from that to to this list
that we're talking about right here well
probably in time I know we can do that
right here right now because it's just
the epidemic has been a little bit of a
growing concern but really the last
month really a great concern but I do
think players maybe don't play as long
as I used to and I think that you're
going to see that list become rare and
the 300 Win Club I think you may have
seen the last one for a long time yeah I
mean we're look for ya before you see
another pitcher win 300 games
Bartolo colognes not making it although
man he is what's going on with that you
see how he's getting from from the mound
to first base to about that I'm going
going up
you know scoreless no-hit scoreless
innings for no-hit scoreless innings
with Verlander couple weeks ago yeah
then there's CC then there's Verlander
who's a hundred and eight win shy
Greinke Felix ended up yeah who's gonna
catch it Kershaw is a hundred and fifty
five wins Charlotte no he's your 11 it's
one of the best pictures in the era and
not not halfway there now the reason for
that is what lack of complete games or
this whole business of or is it or is it
the metric of taking pictures out
because there just happened to be in the
third go-round of the batting order I
think all of it adds up all of it adds
up to less wins but I do think that it's
I don't know if players are gonna play
as like the season is a grind the season
takes its toll on everybody and I don't
know if the appetite will be there to
continue to pitch when you think about
winning 300 games you're talking about a
lot of victories and a lot of seasons
tremendous amount of seasons in the
upper echelon of your of your wind group
think about 20 game winners we haven't
seen a lot of those either
once in a while you'll see it the record
that will never be broken
probably Ripken with the little Garrick
and second with game streaks right
complete games obsolete
absolutely well and and another through
line can be drawn from from what I'm
hearing from our guests that have been
on the show please a Cal lidar Smoltz
just to name some pitchers is the fact
of the specialization of the bullpen yes
also leads to more strikeouts because
it's different ventures live arms
different arm angles one inning after
another after another that's adding two
more strikeouts you know we saw this kid
Josh hater strike out a e1 for 8 for 8
the other night yes for the Milwaukee
Brewers but what about the mindset of
the prospect are you seeing different
from you know and your your your days to
the current days that you're now V
seeing is an analyst the kids just are
they taught at an age now just don't
worry about the strikeout is that what
being taught that's a lot of it
strikeout used to end the career as a
nine-year-old if you couldn't hit as an
annular struck eyelid you were done
that's no longer the case and I think
that in player development I think
people are teaching loft they're
teaching put the ball in the air they're
teaching you know power pays and go for
the long ball and if you strike out you
strike out because it used to be nobody
nobody wanted to strike out and if you
looked at the all-time strikeout leaders
and as hitters we're some of the great
power hitters of all time it was a
dynamic that they held but now as you
look at who leads leagues and strikeouts
and who strikes out a lot it's a six
hitter it's a seventh hitter it's not
the three four or five guys it's it's
pretty much all the way up and down that
line up I think kids are taught
different I think the emphasis is on
power more than putting the ball on play
and you rarely see a hitter with a
two-strike approach you used to always
see hitters choke up go to right field
at least make contact move a runner
along make it a productive out you don't
see a lot of that you'll see it once in
a while with some of the greats
but you don't see it as as a integral
part of a strategic mind of a hitter so
how much is analytics playing a role in
this it could play a big role in it you
know there's numbers that say that then
are you're gonna score X number of runs
by putting a ball in the air that that's
that's how to do it it could be that but
I do think that there's only there's one
thing worse than a strikeout in the game
well kind of to a triple play but really
a double play is a strikeout gets you
nothing and the onion when you flip it
and it talked about the relievers that
some of those pitchers brought up the
the idea that you could come in and get
a strike out sometimes is necessary as a
relief pitcher you don't need a fly ball
you don't need a ground ball in the hole
or something that can drive a runner and
remove a runner along you need that
strikeout so I think it plays into that
role too because the bullpens are
different and they are better years ago
you had starting a starting rotation and
a closer then a setup guy became the
next level then a lefty a left on left
guy then maybe a lefty setup guy and so
little by little you've crawled this
back but as you put together your
pitching staff your 12th or 13th pitcher
are typically the ones that are
borderline they're going to be
interchangeable as time goes on if
they're gonna stick in the show they're
gonna the strike guys out well
Coletti here in the Rich Eisen show what
can be done about it because something
has to be done because to me and I said
this many times I'll say it again with
you here baseball has to realize forget
time a game I would rather see a ton of
hits and it takes 300 3 hours and 20
minutes
I really would then to see what I saw
with the Yankees in the Astros the other
night which was no score at all 28 of
the 54 outs in the game with strikeouts
more than half with strikeouts and I
would rather see something fixed with
the strikeouts cuz you're seeing no
action at all 0 action and that's a
problem in the 21st century although it
all need to see something so what does
what should baseball do and I will then
give you a suggestion that I had to
bounce that one off you what what should
baseball do for a fix philosophies are
tough to change I think they had they
can only change when when there's such
mounting evidence that it's it's hurting
your club or hurting your organization I
think then it changes back but until
that point I think everything will stay
stay the way it is and make it worse but
it's it's sad to say it's sad to talk
about or it's against my you know
traditional belief on how the game is
best played but I think until teams lose
so much because of a philosophy that's
in place like like swing hard and try to
loft and get lost and going you know
we're gonna live on an exit velocity and
tell the Intel that is a philosophical
change that your team is losing 90 to
100 games a year with that philosophy I
think it stays and it runs its course
well how about getting rid of the shift
make it because football it has to use
the analogy football has changed some
rules to benefit the offense more
scoring defensive penalties and and and
they put the onus on the defense quite a
bit to keep your hands off of receivers
can't hit the quarterback in a certain
way can't touch a receiver in a certain
way scoring goes up more and more people
are enjoying fantasy football in that
regard potentially what about removing
the shift and making it easier to get
singles I go back and forth on it I know
the shift you should be rare that you'd
ever see a shift I knew Lou Boudreau
who allegedly had the first shift
against Ted Williams you know 6070 years
ago and it was rare you'd ever see it
now you see it every game I go back and
forth on it because I do think you know
it's a little bit overdone but there is
a way to break it - they have not they
have not made the playing field fair
territory less square footage as a
hitter if you're a left-handed hitter
and they got everybody over to the right
side you can't hit the ball down the
left field line or bunt the ball down
the third-base line do that and I think
nobody's nobody spent the last several
years going to Fenway Park hoping to see
poppy bunt his way on I mean we've got
to think about the greater I get
attention and I get balls and an
excitement and buzz and tweeting videos
out nobody's tweeting on the only
strikeouts I saw tweeted out where this
kid you know hater because there were
eight of them and eight you know this is
the metric that needs to be focused on
when you're going deeper into the 21st
century here for eyeballs I'm not sure
what you can do about it you know maybe
that's why they're swinging irons and
left so they can hit it over the shift
but that's right that's what I was
saying the other day again that this you
get rid of the shift maybe fewer people
will try and hit it you know into the
shift and instead of over it yeah well I
think a good hitter a guy like Tony
Gwynn made a living going the opposite
way it would be so hard to shift on Tony
Gwynn be almost impossible he was a
hitter that could hit the off field sure
if you're a Red Sox fan you want to see
a Big Papi hit it out in little bullpen
you know we're headed over the monster
but at the same time to play the game to
win the game a defense if a defense
knows that you're likely to do that that
you may drop the ball down a third base
line or you can just slap it down with
it the guy we just talked about at the
outset of this this segment each year oh
yeah master at it how do you shift on
that you can't shift on it because what
your end up gonna do you're gonna end up
giving up a double instead of a single
if you're playing it wrong defensively
that takes it out of the game they shift
because it's a it's a percentage play
that this is where this player is gonna
hit the ball because history tells us
this is what they do
sometimes you got to change your history
your personal history to to change it up
that great chat man
pleasure let's say you're just down the
street where anytime let's do this more
often
anytime you got a buddy and your book is
still available obviously I'm absolutely
doing well I'll sell it online
bookstores everywhere the big chair
smooth hops and bad bounces from the
inside world of the acclaimed Los
Angeles Dodgers general manager good to
see you net thank you sir
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience